He cannot take accountability. He will never take accountability.
He just has to blame everyone else. And so, when he's at 2,000
viewers and Hasan's at 60,000 viewers, he seethes and seethes
and seethes to the point that he's going to call for this guy's
death. Hey, Dan, start tracking this guy's location in real life.
>> Okay. This is a person who has quite literally debated
to the ends of time that I'm a more dangerous figure for America
than Adolf Hitler. He has said that he would rather vote for
Adolf Hitler than vote for someone like
>> When [music] you have ICE agents sieging, laying siege
on American cities, Americans, and you're going to a guy that
you are supposed to get political opinions from, and the guy
that you're supposed to get political opinions from is like,
"Well, you know who's actually really the villain here? Hasan."
They're Eventually, people are going to be like, "Actually, he's
out there. You're just on him from your house." AND OH, [__]
I SAID THIS. OH, I SAID THIS. I don't know if I put this on stream,
but I just laughed at people [__] on Hasan here.
It's like, "Bro, this guy's going out in the cold. He's given
hand warmers to the people. And you're going to sit there and
[__] on him? He's going out there. He's going to
the Well, I don't know what they got for a district in Minnesota,
but he's going to the workers, okay? He's handed out hand warmers.
He's handed out like hot chocolate. He's He's going out there.
He's doing some mutual aid, okay? He even called it mutual aid.
I was like, "Bro, you just pay people to go buy those those hot
packs or those um those hand warmers." But, he's actually out
there. He's trying to do stuff. And you can't deny that, right?
He is trying to do stuff. If you sit at home on your ass, obese
on your couch,
and you criticize Hasan, okay? I question your motives. It seems
like he's doing everything that's right. You got to give it up
to him when he goes to the protest where people are getting shot
as a famous like left-winger,
and he's just like helping those people out. And then you're
like, "Oh, this guy is This guy is a total piece of shit." No,
he's not a total piece of [__] He is helping people.
He is like trying to do his best. He's trying. Now, does he gain
from that? Yeah.
But, I Dude, the guy is trying and a lot of other people aren't.
Hard for me to go hard on other people, you know? Hard for me
to go hard on Hasan when he's doing so much more than other people.
And I don't agree with you. And that's that change is coming.
That's why I said woke is good back.
We do know this is why Hasan is impervious to assassination,
okay? A head shot on Hasan, borderline
Borderline impossible, okay? The mass of his shoulders around
his tiny head actually warps light in such a way that you would
never be able to kill this guy in one shot, okay? He He can't
be sniped. He can't be sniped. Light bends around these shoulders
away from his tiny head in a way that you'll never be able to
shoot him correctly, ever. It's impossible. Can't be done.
That's why I'm saying woke is eventually going to be back.
They can't comprehend why adults that are invested in the political
process will turn around and and, you know, court me for my opinion,
whether they be actual politicians, whether they be politicians
that actually worked in the previous administration, politicians
with ambitions for higher office, or all of these media outlets
that that come to me to to hear what my perspective is. They're
like, "It doesn't make sense. Like, why are they
not seeing what I see? Maybe it's because your brain is infested
with worms, okay? That's it. That's it. There are still more
who are doing this, too. The whole like
Like, look. Instead of posting the actual clip, Jeremiah Johnson,
another one of these like liberal ops, okay? Who is a horrible,
horrible figure with no emotion whatsoever, but like still grasping
to this like uh grasping on to this like, "No, actually, Democrats,
please don't become more radicalized, okay? Please don't become
more radicalized. Please, no matter what you do, don't become
more radicalized. Don't Don't actually fight back. Democrats,
don't do it." And he just clip chimps like a 5-minute video that
I Oh.
Oh, [__] We actually are going to continue through
this.
We will go back to some other stuff right after this, but I did
see this clip and I'm like, "Man, like the guy's out there doing
shit."
He has criticisms for Democrats, but he shouldn't be somebody
who never criticizes Democrats. That's not his position. That
shouldn't be incumbent on him to never ever ever ever ever criticize
Dems ever. That's [__] stupid, man.
I did with Mint Press.
And you listen
Yes, I know. I know the Goombas from the original Mario movie
are very much like Hasan. I'm aware.
Let's try to Listen, be cool, man. Be cool. We got a bunch of
We got a bunch of Oilers in the channel who are big Hasan fans
now, okay? Be cool, dog. Be
We can't We can't do that all the time now, okay? We actually
can and we will be We will be doing it. We will be pointing out
that Hasan is like the Goombas from the original Mario movie
very often. >> talk to me last night.
Under Barack Obama at the time, a lot of Democrats were not very
fond of Black Lives Matter, which is true.
This is not a testament to like the Democratic Party being like
completely evil or whatever. I think it's a testament to how
the Democratic Party is out of step with what people want.
What's wrong with Jeremiah Johnson? I mean, he's another one
of these shitlibs who is like uh constantly leading the Democratic
Party astray or trying to do
A lot of these guys are also super super super pro-Israel, and
they just like won't get They They just cannot >> just
be your pay pig. >> Oh, hold on. Hold on. Hello.
Let's go.
Hold on. What's your prediction for the future? So, I think there's
a couple things running together here, Fairy Queen. Hold on.
I'm I'm going to read the rest of your donation. Just give me
a second. I have to go to the website.
What's your prediction for the future after the dust has all
settled? I think the reason people become famous is to That is
unironically why most people become famous. Most people are driven
to become famous, driven to pursue some field because they see
that it's monetary and it's or at least it's why they after the
first blow up. You know, they're trying to [__] A
lot of people get groupies. A lot of people get famous get groupies
or or just like Yeah, they they start developing, you know, drug
addictions, addiction, all of these things. So, I think a lot
of these guys got famous, and then when women wanted to be around
them, they took advantage of that. The problem, I guess, is delineating
where that becomes acceptable versus
you know, where is that acceptable? How did they use their influence?
Did they do something that's like scummy? What can you judge
them for? There's a lot of different things going on here at
the same time. Like, people like famous people. Women Women like
famous people. I'm sure guys like famous women, too. I'm sure
if women if women weren't already, you know, beating dudes off,
ha
I'm sure like Sydney Sweeney would have a bunch of groupies,
right? It just happens to be that guys are the chasers usually.
Guys are the people who, ha ha, in In Britain's case, more often
than you'd expect. It Guys usually are the pursuers, women are
the pursued, and guys happen to always want So, I'd say with
regards to somebody like Sydney Sweeney or like, I don't know,
big musicians, Taylor Swift and They could probably [__]
all the time if they wanted to, right? It's not something they
pursue. Guys will pursue that, and they will get laid a lot,
and it's basically like, how are they how upfront are they? How
do they use their power? How are they How are they using their
power if they're accused of something? There's a lot of different
dynamics there. What's the prediction? Famous dudes will keep
and there will be a difficult time We'll have a difficult time
differentiating
people who are upset that they didn't progress to a relationship
and people who are upset because they were unjustifiably like
manipulated or maligned in some way. So, it'll be difficult to
understand, difficult to know for sure,
And the lines will be blurred, and we've got like cultural
We've got like cultural battle lines on this as well, where basically,
you know, more left-leaning people always take the the side of
the accuser, more right-leaning people always take the side of
the accused.
It's probably just going to become muddier and harder muddier
and harder to understand unless people have like hard
Yeah. I think there's like so many different things going on
at the same time, right?
Wait, what? Well, for sure, Cuoco takes advantage of her popularity
in that regard, too. I'm not sure what you mean here, Kyoko,
but you want to explain? I could I could maybe take a look. That's
a very complicated question, though. I do think it's like Basically,
the answer is it's really difficult to sift through and understand
these things, and that's why there's actually a lot of content
in doing that, in trying to like go through all of the evidence
in a in some accusation,
figuring out what's happening there, who's in the wrong, what
you can determine based on what evidence you have. I think that's
why it's such compelling content to people because it's just
difficult to tell, man. And you need somebody who's like really
up to up to date on all of the information to get their
Have you ever seen influencer videos from India? Men of all ages
are groupies there. Oh, interesting. No, I haven't.
I don't disagree that people will continue to want to become
famous to have sex. I think you're right, sadly, that boundary
violation from rich people to smaller creators will likely continue.
Um it's like You You could have better standards there. I do
think
I do think if you're not willing to call out all of like the
the famous people using their status to get laid stuff, I think
it's hard for you to stand on just streamers shouldn't do it.
The issue is the issue is probably the breakdown of institutional
power in a general sense. You used to become famous, you get
like a record deal, and then you have somebody who like sort
of watched over you. Now it's like you get famous independently,
right? And there's nobody who can like even punish you for something.
So, you could kind of blur the lines and take advantage of people
in a way that's really difficult to track. I don't know that
there is a solution for that to be honest with you. I actually
I really don't know, man. It's It's tough.
And like you could change societal norms so that it's like wrong
to sleep with somebody who finds you via your content. You could
change societal norms, but then I don't I don't know that there
will ever be broad support for those
Yeah, it's
weird. The lawsuits are probably going to eventually become a
problem. Well, here's the thing with Techtone, I think there
was smoke there, like legitimate smoke. With somebody like if
you go back to Aziz Ansari, I think he got an allegation and
then mostly
people were like, oh, we take his side. I do think there's a
way to act so that it's mostly, you know, if you're being accused
or if you're the accuser, there're probably ways to act that
you such that you can be supported by a majority of people.
That's my opinion.
Um usually when it's like totally gray and you can't understand
it at all,
man, I don't know. The The thing we're seeing the problem I'm
seeing recently is that people turn it into gray via their audiences.
That something can be black and white and via your audience,
via your influence, you can actually like manipulate this narrative
to the point that it becomes gray and people sort of back away.
That's That's the main problem I'm seeing right now, but I haven't
followed like a ton of this stuff. Well, I followed probably
more than most. I think that's the bigger thing, right?
Believe all women was a mistake? Sure.
But you don't have to believe all women. I'm of the opinion,
and maybe I'm just schizophrenic in this, that you can sort of
like bifurcate your mind and both believe the victim and the
accused.
Right? Like I don't think you should necessarily I said this
when the original Destiny stuff popped. I'm like, I don't care
if you keep watching him,
Like I think he's lost some moral authority, but I I didn't think
it was that big a deal. Then he went turned into a total psychopath,
but that's neither here nor there. I think you can give a lot
of people the benefit of the doubt. Like with Mizkif, I think
with Mizkif, with his assault allegation, I actually think there's
a chance he just misread the situation, that he didn't do something
totally outside the norm, and that for that one specific thing,
judgment on him is not really required. Judgment on him is not
really
But Mizkif's done a lot of other things that you could judge
him for.
I think with that specific thing, I but at the same time as I
believe Mizkif was sort of hard done by, right? With regards
to that allegation, especially with the influencers who took
Emiru's side, I understand how Emiru makes that allegation, how
she feels
The Emiru one, I also think the QTCinderella one is not really
The QTCinderella one is about power dynamics. It's not really
that she was raped or something. She She pretty clearly says
like, I decided to, you know, consent because I was feeling drunk.
And it's like, well, unfortunately, if Mizkif was also drunk,
that sort of turns into a wash for me.
Um I didn't know there was a third one, Z Z. I actually don't
know about that
Like Mizkif, to me, the assault thing doesn't even measure up.
Like the the two allegations of driving over 100 miles an hour
while he's upset with his partner, that hits way harder for me
than any of this assault stuff that Mizkif's been accused of.
Right? In terms of negative like moral
It's pretty obvious. Anyway, uh-oh, we had a Twitch message that
was held. What? What was this?
Allow list. Oh, then Oh, this guy This guy was mad at me the
other night, too. Then you're a [__] You are specifically
watering down the narrative at the moment. Go [__]
yourself. Evidence is evidence. Not up to your opinion, douche
canoe.
This guy, he's very mad at me. Wait, with regards to what? With
regards to
What? Huh?
That seems excessive, man.
I already said that I already said I have criticisms for
I'm not going to ever hide that. If Mizkif doesn't like that
I have criticisms for him and some of the behavior, then I don't
know what to tell you, man. That it is what it is.
I just don't think he's a
That's my opinion.
They have this take where it's like the Democrats will never
do anything right or the Democrats can't ever The Democrats should
never do anything at all and you should never hold them to account.
You should never demand more from them.
Right? Your opinion? Okay, Wolf Raza, what is the evidence in
the Mizkif case?
By the way, discord.gg/jcsokay,
I would love for you to come on and argue this with me cuz I
could just explain to you my opinion.
I can explain to you how I think about All right. You can hop
on if you want. You can come in, you can you can explain why
you think it's like inappropriate for me to think Mizkif is not
a The new talking points have been unlocked. >> Oh. Oh,
[__] This Xbyte guy. Wait, ain't no way you're defending
Red dog. Hop on the stream. Let's [__] go.
You guys want to argue about this? I can totally argue about
this.
>> told me this morning that what you said was hurting
the Democrats and I said, "Brother, they're doing that to themselves."
Because a woman said no. Wait. Or because a woman said so. Okay,
never mind. Never mind.
I know. I saw a rage just now. >> what I said, Kilo. That's
my point. >> I know. I saw that. Okay, we're done with
this one.
I think we have one more part here. I think I was told what,
50? I got given a timestamp for the other stuff is Thomas covering
today. 1 second.
50 57.
So, we'll see if these people are going to call in. I hope they
do. I hope they do. I hope they do.
Pause. Pause. Pause.
Is there anybody calling in? Wolf Raza, you want to call in?
We chat about it?
Xbyte, you want to call in? We can chat about it. Let me see
here. Let me see. Let me see. Let me see.
Nothing. Nothing. I'm lucky.
So, that's the that's the situation, but that's not the only
thing that was going
Um if you want to understand once again the charlatans out there,
okay? If you want to understand like there's a lot of people
who are actually a lot more intelligent than Los Pollos, right?
Like Los Pollos is like the classic, "I'm a a political. What
are you doing? I'm a political." That kind of thing, right? And
yet there are people who are actually liberal, right? Who present
themselves as liberals, who actually
have a a you know, not like a very big not like a giant audience,
definitely an audience that is diminishing, but like spend all
of their time still looking at horrible things that are happening
and then somehow finding a way to tie it back to their, you know,
to the person that they despise the most.
Um to which I That was of course that of of course is Destiny.
Uh also known as best at
Damn. Destiny spite based? No way. Um who Don't forget that Emiru
physically assaulted Miz via Kirby's rabbits through negligence
and allegedly groomed a child. Who's the real monster here? I
don't have to attack Emiru, either. I feel like it's probably
as much as I enjoyed it at the time cuz it was drama. I don't
have to attack Emiru. I think she can totally feel like she was
You just as a as a neutral third observer, as a as a neutral
arbiter, you have to be able to tell people like how it is and
say that like the other side's understandable.
It's incumbent on you as a third party to not be like emotionally
encumbered by that situation. Uh saw the the American Gestapo
laying siege on Minneapolis, Minnesota
and then turned around and was like, "I'm actually really mad
that uh
you know, Hasan is out there protesting. I'm not going to go
outside and protest myself. Of course, I would never do that
cuz I'm a I'm a coward, but I will also from my cowardly
from from tower >> of privilege
uh in my own
in my own home
will demand that my cult-like audience
I will say I thought Destiny's whole criticism of Hasan before
was Hasan doesn't get his hands dirty. Hasan's never going to
go out and canvas. Hasan went to this protest. He handed out
the hand warmers. He did the He did the
Like I I thought that was the criticism was he doesn't do any
actual mutual aid. He doesn't do anything. Why are you super
mad?
Make his presence as uncomfortable as possible until he's forced
to pack up and [__] off back to his wee ho mansion.
He's a CCP paid agitator.
This seems like in
This seems insanely spiteful for me. I I don't even want to cover
this, but it's like it's crazy how spiteful it is,
Don't let this paid CCP agitator give you a hand warmer. That
would be THAT'S A COMMUNIST HAND WARMER.
WHAT? BROTHER, what are you saying? >> audience go and
disrupt what he's trying to do so that we can get a [__]
LSF clip off. Cuz if you noticed,
if you noticed like there weren't any LSF clips off of the the
protest streams even though, you
He hasn't done anything in USA IRL since Charlie died. Wait,
Hasan or Destiny?
Kacey Cavu. Wait, what are you talking about? Why do you think
Destiny's saying, "Don't let paid CCP paid agitators infiltrate
liberal crowds of protesters. Make his presence as What do you
think Destiny's talking about here?"
Wait, what what? Hasan.
Do you not understand that Hasan was out there during the protest
in Minnesota? He was at those protests protests?
He's literally there.
70,000 people were watching because they don't make it there.
The only clips that make it there are ones that these guys try
to manipulate Are you That's really rough if you're unaware of
that, Kacey Cavu, my friend. >> way to try to make it seem
as though it's like a super negative thing. And it's gone beyond
now. He's just like genuinely trying to get me
This was I I'm Somebody sent me this and I first was like, "You
know what? I'm not going to talk about it." And then I I thought
about it. I'm like, "Dude, it's actually like it's nuts."
If Dan wants to do something useful and still be a Hassan hater,
he should create a track Hassan X account that posts his current
location when he's out at protests.
His location should be publicly available at all times while
he's live
Do you remember what happened when Destiny when somebody posted
a picture of Destiny on Twitter and said somebody should egg
him?
Do you guys remember how he handled that? Like I
I don't know.
At the Yes, at the debate college thing.
This is I don't understand how you could possibly And again,
it's just another thing where he totally goes back on any principle
he had. He doesn't believe in anything. He doesn't think any
No principles, no beliefs, nothing underlying, just spite for
people he hates. Just spite for people who are doing better than
him. Just spite It's so weird, man.
And I haven't even gotten into the Pisco stuff, which also disgusts
me. I think Destiny, the only reason Destiny gets like a pop
during like big political events is cuz nobody's replaced him
as a liberal and he's attacking all of his best competition as
a liberal
Right? That's why he keeps attacking Pisco. That's why he keeps
it inventing reasons to attack Pisco because he knows that that's
the best replacement he could have.
Right? And he has to keep on Pisco over and over and over again
because he's a spiteful loser who is terrified of getting replaced
as the primary liberal commentator on YouTube, right? As one
of the primary ones. He's terrified of it. He's scared as
that Pisco is going to replace him and so he's just going to
keep denigrating Pisco to his audience over and over and over
again.
It's so stupid, man. >> um using his cult to try to Pisco
and Josiah still speak fondly of Destiny.
Um they were doing it yesterday even.
I don't know why Pisco should understand that this guy wants
him dead. This guy wants his channel dead.
Pisco better If Pisco doesn't understand it, maybe Pisco Pisco
does have a lot of viewers who overlap, but if Pisco doesn't
get it, this guy doesn't want you to succeed. He wants you
I hope he starts to get it after a little while.
direct crosshair on me, like direct target on me. I don't know
why he won't just like focus on being a normal human
But this dork ass cult loser
said, "You have a moral obligation to bully the [__]
out of this guy if you ever see him in one of your protests.
Don't let the CCP paid agitators infiltrate liberal crowds of
protesters. Make his presence as uncomfortable as possible until
he's forced to pack up and [__] off back to his Wee
Home
First they say, "All you do is sit in your Wee Home Mansion."
And then when I'm not there, they go, "Oh, yeah."
YEAH. LIKE I'M SORRY. I hate to Dude, I said it before he says
it. It's so nuts. What are you supposed to do, man? What what
the [__] is this on? Hassan's evil. He's damned if
he does he he's damned if he doesn't.
Bro, Hassan is bad.
That's all that it is. >> bully you until you go back to
your Wee Home Mansion. Now, of course, he's saying this kind
of thing
um because he's a loser. Like this is it. If you are a fan of
Destiny, understand, please. I know there's a lot of haters that
come in here to like look at all the clips and stuff to try to
see if they can find something to disparage me or smear me or
whatever. He has led you astray. This is all This is all he cares
about, okay? This is all he cares
This is all he cares about, nothing else. He just masquerades
as a liberal.
And maybe he has some liberal points of view. He really does
hate Republicans for one reason or another. There's plenty of
reasons to hate Republicans. I will say that. And he's a good
debater. I will also admit that as well. But at the end of the
day, his world view is hollow, okay? There's nothing there. It's
just pure spite.
This way Oh, damn. Huh. Wow. I'm I'm psychically communicating
with Hassan through time and space, okay? Back in time, this
happened 7 hours ago or something, but I'm communicating with
him to explain how how this works, okay? Hassan, we're mentally
linked. We're mentally linked. Keep going. Keep going. Keep going.
or envious or mad that
that that there's someone else out there that liberals are paying
attention to and not him, right? But instead, this is a serious
Send me Somebody send me the log now, okay? Send me the log.
I'll mark concurrent viewers by then Hassan by 2025 or 2026,
whatever the [__] SEND ME THE LOG NOW.
reasonable disagreement and ideological disagreement that he
has with me. Okay? If you genuinely were invested in
if you were genuinely invested in like uh combating Republicans,
right? At at this point, you probably would not align yourself
historically with so many and [__] like that. But
then also on top of that, you wouldn't be focusing on this, right?
You wouldn't be focusing on this at all. This entire drama space
on the internet
this entire drama space on the internet where like all these
other like drama farmers go to is led by individuals that have
no investment in politics at all that are totally sheltered from
the impact of politics because they make like a decent amount
of money and they could just stay at their home. >> what
you're saying. And then they will substitute
Hold on. Hold on. I just Dude, I'm sorry. I'm sorry I can't help
it. I can't help it, okay?
I can't help it.
This is all you need to understand to find out why Destiny is
upset, okay? This is all you need to understand. This explains
everything that's going on
Ah, it was just it was Destiny at like 2,000 viewers and Hassan
at 60,000,
That's all it was. Those are the comparisons. That's why he's
mad. That's why he's upset because he said he was going to have
more concurrent viewership than Hassan by 2025
and then he totally fell short and now he's angry and he's lashing
out at anybody he feels is responsible except for himself. Will
never take accountability for his own actions. Will never take
accountability for the things he's done. He's just has to blame
everybody else for the things going wrong in his life. He cannot
take accountability. He will never take accountability. He just
has to blame everyone else. And so when he's at 2,000 viewers
and Hassan's at 60,000 viewers, he seethes and seethes and seethes
to the point that he's going to call for this guy's death. Hey
Dan, start tracking this guy's location in real
That's the whole point, okay? That's where I was going with those
pictures. I don't know what you're talking about. >> like
total weirdos.
But the reason why I'm also talking about Yeah, and then he blamed
me. He cried and blamed me for it, too.
Here's what you said about his dad at the time. Yeah.
where is the OG tweet? I think the OG post is on Oh, I went back
to the tech tone thing. Whoops. Whoops. Like they they only look
at politics through the lens of drama
where personal grievances and envy
is presented as significant political disagreements that must
be addressed where organized smear campaigns
clipping people out of context, making it seem like they didn't
they said something that they didn't say, making it seem like
they didn't they believe something that they don't believe uh
are treated like accountability initiatives, right? That's what
they do.
It's not actually about accountability. It's just one man's personal
vendetta. And moments like this clearly show that
This is a person who has quite literally debated to the ends
of time that I'm a more dangerous figure for America than He
has said that he would rather vote for Adolf Hit
than vote for someone like myself.
That's not even a joke. And for a lot of people that are in the
commentary sphere that think this guy is like uh you know, brilliant
even though his own personal audience is basically like a cult
and and doesn't have a lot of motion, uh they do end up swinging
That's not true. Unfortunately for Hassan, that's not true. They
do have >> class with regular frequency cuz they have they're
very on >> There's a post. Oh, I didn't know it was a Reddit
post in whatever the leftovers
I just saw it I saw it somewhere else.
versus political streamer 2.8k
uh 64k. This is These were the two pictures I was looking for.
Somebody just posted them somewhere else.
I see. Haha. Yes, this is this is why Destiny's mad at Hassan
right now, okay?
That's not Austin, is it? It's not. Sorry, I don't know why I
thought it was.
online, they brigade Reddit all the time. They've been using
LSF as like a sleeve for the longest time.
and that's it.
They look to they look to every single thing that I do here not
as like a point to to organize around, even if they are supposed
to be in agreement with it, but a point to like criticize. They're
like, "Oh, well, he went out there, but also
he actually was doing the wrong He went out there with the wrong
way, you know what I mean? I didn't go out there, of course,
but if I did, I would go out there the right way." And basically,
it's just Gamergate.
It's completely sociopathic. It's a I don't know about that allegation.
That seems weird, but I don't know. >> at this point and
he's just never going to let it go. Um
even though this kind of
even though this kind of sentiment has no motion in the real
world as we see over and over again,
it does have a tendency
to to make people think make people online think twice, right?
Every now and then. And before you say, "Why are we talking about
this? Why Like I just personally feel like the the DGG logs,
the stuff where he's like saying, "Oh, somebody should track
this guy down and post his his like real-time location." I just
think there's enough stuff there with regards to Hasan that's
like that shouldn't be platformed on YouTube. That's obviously
against YouTube TOS. It's obviously like a a linked platform.
Uh they will hit you for stuff off platform on YouTube. The guy's
just objectively like calling for other people to be hurt. Like
repeatedly. There's actually multiple instances over months.
Like he's crashing out so badly.
It it shouldn't be platformed basically anywhere. I don't know
what the rules are on Kick. It's unacceptable, man. >> Why
are we talking about this? And I say that as somebody who's like
I didn't call for his deplatforming right away, right? It's once
he starts like literally advocating for doxxing and and harming
multiple people. I'm just like, "Dude, it's like stop. Stop."
I'll get to it in a second cuz like he is quite literally
"When you go when you organization got denied? Where? Where did
you see that?"
Didn't Destiny dox that girl over the same thing with the egg?
Yes, that's why I pointed out. Do you remember how he reacted
with the egg girl? He doxxed that girl, yeah. >> to protest
like you shouldn't care about the actual protest itself. You
should go out to harass this person. I mean, look I would say
he doxxed her by posting, you know, additional information
intending to harass her. I would say I think she might have had
it connected like she might have, you know, had her full name
there and linked to like her LinkedIn or something. Get the message
out there. >> putting out there to his audience. His audience
has already targeted me in public before. It was a very funny
moment when the at the DNC one of them came and then we found
out that he was a ginormous racist. He was in his own Discord
being like, "Oh, I'm seeing him here. I'm shaking. I'm shaking."
You know, he's done that before and he's also encouraged that
before. But what happens when one of his fans actually has a
knife or a gun? You know what I mean? I think he just hates people
he sees less than himself. He wouldn't do this if he showed up
to support some pro-Palestine
What the hell is Hasan saying is a good
You wouldn't do this if he showed up to support You wouldn't
Uh I think Hasan would still complain. I think if there was some
pro-Palestinian guy who was calling for Hasan to get like followed
and hurt. I do think Hasan would complain, actually. >> position
on Israel even if it's not out of principle. Yeah, if if Yes,
I This is the whole point that I'm making. Dude, what what? And
the point that I'm making is You wouldn't do this. You wouldn't
Oh, you think he meant
No, he said you wouldn't do this if he
You wouldn't do this if you showed some support to pro-Palestinian
protesters. This is This person is definitely saying you wouldn't
as in Hasan. >> utterly unproductive.
Okay? That's the point. If he actually truly cared about combating
ICE, he wouldn't be doing this [__] Why would you
be doing this [__] We're supposed to be on the same
side,
Destiny loves ICE. Destiny reports people to ICE. Listen, Destiny
loves that. Destiny loves when people get reported ICE. >> But
he doesn't care. What are you talking about? >> stuff is
just another way to get an own. Ethan Klein does this all the
time as well. He rarely ever talks about any of the ongoing incidents
around the world unless he can like somehow tie it back to iDubbz
or tie it back to me. He's posted more Wait, Matt, you don't
know about the part where he took the the person who's suing
him apparently was in a marriage so that their friend could get
a green card or something.
And Destiny basically posted and said, "This is a fraudulent
marriage. Blah blah blah blah blah." Took his DMs, dumped them,
and then
I think he might have either either signal boosted or straight
up approved Myron Gains coming along and saying we should report
Pixie to ICE. Oh, you didn't know about that? Yeah, that that
definitely happened.
More about me on his Instagram stories. And every time I see
it it's like a jump >> let's go. >> 15 Instagram
stories in a row of him like trying to yell at me.
He cares more about that stuff. He cares more about like using
any and everything that's going on in a way to to dunk on me
than to actually address the the the real atrocities
It is a legitimate marriage.
Maybe. I don't know about that.
>> psychotic. Now many of you in this community don't even
know this stuff because I rarely ever cover it because I feel
like it's utterly unproductive and very stupid to cover it. I
have a job to do. My job is to explain the news to people, right?
My job is to try to get people out there to organize, to try
to
I support ICE. Am I a bad person?
It depends on what you mean. Do you mean you support the execution
of that dude who was like lying on the ground? If you support
that, yeah, you're probably a bad person. If you're trying to
play some language game by saying I support ISIS and you support
the idea of having immigration or borders, you're a and you should
actually consider um Canadian health care? Is that how we say
ISIS protecting American citizens by shooting American citizens
in the back? You're a not worth talking to. >> Stop the
Trump administration.
And it's crazy that these guys will just No, that was crazy.
Okay, well then that's what we're mad about. >> Well, you
know, we'll just vote for Kamala Harris and then that's it. That's
it. That's nothing else, okay? And then we'll also never But
you should understand, LeBron James' hairline, that you came
in here trying to do some like little wedge thing. You're trying
to be like a total Epsler, okay? Trying to go, "Eh I support
ICE. I support like borders and immigration brought Yeah, everybody
does. Everybody's obviously mad about a little bit more than
trying to maintain a border right now.
Trying to turn it into something else, trying to to like make
people upset with something else. Insane. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You
are a total I I totally soul read you the second you typed your
first
Yeah, you're you're soul read. You should You should leave in
disgrace right now.
>> And uh we'll never do anything. And the only time we
ever bring uh anything up, the only time we ever criticize anything
that's going on is to somehow make it a dunk on, you know, people
like myself, people like on on the left.
Okay? It's just crazy to me. In any case
obviously this is utterly motionless
But the reason why I'm bring bringing it up is because he's straight
up saying "If Dan wants to do something useful and still be a
Hasan
Hasan's smart here, he'll pull up the previous times Destiny
said that you could justify Hasan. >> should create a track
Hasan Twitter account that posts his current location when he's
out at protest. His location should be publicly available at
all times while he's live streaming. This is him and his cult.
This is this morning.
Telling his his uh co-host, his podcast co-host, Dan Stalkman
who has been trying to get me
Don't talk about Dan being old. >> uh worked alongside
the ADL and things like that to actively get a bunch of pro-Palestine
people deplatformed on this platform for Somehow that agitates
Dan more than anything, more than anti-Semitism. You comment
on Dan's age, he gets like way more mad about that than anything.
I don't get it.
Like you're you're just you're a bit older than the average people
that compete It's It seems like something you should be pretty
immune to. I don't know >> the now majority position, right?
He's telling him like, "Don't just stalk him the way that you've
been stalking
Stalk him better.
Stalk him directly.
Stalk him harder. Stalk him now.
Yeah, this is the other thing that I was talking about. Look.
I said the siege on Minneapolis
Minnesota is where you really see the West Bank occupation tactics
on US soil. Hasan's constant deflection to Israel is starting
to amount to a defense of Donald Trump. He's shifting the blame
off Trump every time he does this. This is the dumbest way to
[__]
No, he's not.
How is he deflecting the
Ethan believes there's like total uh like total war crimes taking
place in the West Bank. That's Ethan's opinion.
How How is saying, "Oh, under Trump we're doing war crimes on
US soil now." How is that a defense of Trump? Are you actually
too stupid to function, Ethan >> tried to argue and he
of course clipped my perspective out of context once again. But
that's what I mean. These these guys cannot argue on the virtues.
Yeah, and remember this person has uh literally openly stated
that it would be totally justifiable to attack and kill me in
real life.
>> This person who has solicited nudes from a minor
>> There it is. There it is. There it is.
>> A civil court case that's ongoing
um because he distributed
revenge
and his victims got together and sued him. And he spent every
waking moment presenting himself as as like this with this woke
guy on the one side. Not even a woke guy, he's very edgy. He
loves to say slurs and [__] But like a a liberal
debate god while simultaneously
he's doing stuff that's like completely antithetical to being
in any way, shape, or form
protective of minority populations. He's even like fantasized
about calling ICE on one of his victims.
By the way, Destiny's too much of a [__] to ever
go on his live stream and say these same opinions that he'll
put in text. He won't do it. He's just way too much of a [__]
He knows he's like scared. He's totally scared of losing his
YouTube, losing his relevancy. He is too scared to do it. So
when he goes he he used to say things like with regards to the
doxxing, okay? Oh, he Wait, hold on. Wait, he did? OH, NO WAY.
Why is he just trying to bait him into saying it? So thank you,
I was hoping that somebody would get him a clip of this or that
he's like watching at some point soon and I could bait him into
like trying to get himself banned from YouTube. But if he's done
it already, then thank god. Right?
This is just misinformation though, yikes. What do you mean,
misinformation?
Wait, this can't be the navy thing. Don't Don't be the navy thing.
Got to be recent.
Oh god, his like own [clears throat] chatter is going to clip
this. This is not good, man. If you are
He's paid by Israel source Norm Finkelstein. I don't know if
he's actually paid by Israel. I know Norm thinks so, but Maybe.
I mean, he has gone to Israel. He has defended Israel vociferously.
I mean, there's no way he's demonetized for statements on Charlie
Kirk and he actually makes a statement about Hasan. I got to
say Okay, publicly available at all times while he's live streaming.
This is him at his cult.
I just want to clarify what I was saying here cuz it sounds like
um
It sounds like I'm saying that his like live location or whatever
should be broadcast or whatever I was approaching.
Oh, he's got to do that. >> exactly what I'm saying and
it should be and he should be bullied. People should scream at
him and shout at him.
Um By the way, Mr. Mouton totally loves all of these comments
about dehumanizing people, about doxxing, about hurting people.
He's here for all of it. Um I called this out before and people
got really mad. This is who you guys are. This is literally who
you guys are. That's just it. And it should be and he should
be bullied. People should scream at him and shout at him and
bully him the out of any left-leaning protest that you see. The
CCP paid adj
Mouton is getting a bag for like the most immediate amount of
time, like right now. Um
He is making himself like totally unpalatable to other people.
And these clips these clips where he just remains silent all
the time, they will follow him. >> should never be in any
democratic liberal protest ever. If he wants to go hang out with
disgusting smelly fat losers, the tankie [__] or
whatever, he can go hang out with those [__] losers.
That's absolutely fine. But until he Apparently, these are all
liberal protests. Apparently, they're just exclusively liberal
protesters. They're not just people who are conscientious objectors
to ICE's conduct, right? Destiny himself not a conscientious
conscientious objector to ICE's conduct. Very happy to report
Pixie and her wife to to ICE, right?
Hasan just a conscientious objector. He wants to go out and protest.
>> public statement that fully accounts for how he was
compensated by the Chinese Communist Party for his little paid
vacation trip with him and the rest of his little streamer to
China. Until he has publicly announced it, addressed it, and
talked about it, I have no idea why the [__] you
would want this guy anywhere near any of your liberal protests.
Absolutely Now, one of the hugest issues that this country has
right now is all of the foreign interference that is just happening
openly on all of our social media platforms by the same countries
that paid this loser to go and do a shill who couldn't even go
through with it. He couldn't even let the guy his neck, okay,
at the stupid chiropractic place cuz he knew how the stuff that
he was was but he was getting paid too much I have no idea what
he's talking about here. I I got to assume that probably you
don't want to be bullied >> by the same by the Chinese
government to say no, okay? So, [__] this guy for
letting him in
It's He's got to do all of these crazy mental gymnastics to try
to justify this totally spite-based opinions he's got. Do you
want to protest? You want to go hang out with Republicans? Go
to the dangerous places and get shot. Okay, all of us will clap
for you, I promise. All right, go to the Republican places. Go
to the edgy places. Go hang out with
It's so sad.
He fell off so hard. He like thinks he's He thinks this is a
very cool rant right now. He thinks like people are loving this
rant. He loves it. He thinks like this is, you know, people are
going to clip this. They're going to love it. Uh one guy clipped
it. This is your guy. 3,800 views in 7
Very cool. Wow.
And so many a bunch of other people are going to sit here and
go, "Actually, uh Hasan's bad that like yeah, you probably this
is fine. This is fine. We should say this."
For sure.
Can we post links? You can post links. >> yeah. But stay
the [__] away from liberal protests.
Did anybody like talk about this? I wonder if there's any commentary
on this today or if it's just all AstroTurfed
Very sad.
Oh, very sad. What are you linking? You're linking a YouTube
timestamp to what? To
Some [__] music? Okay, thank you. >> out of
protest. >> it, dude. Yeah, it's like he thinks it's like
a Destiny moment and it's not. It's like, dude, nobody
Nobody thinks it's cool. I do think there is some poetic like
kind of kind of irony in the fact that Destiny can talk about
people all the time. He can just constantly talk about people
and a lot of people are now just like Dude, [__]
off. Like he's becoming like just Pearly Things unironically
where he's got like these really takes consistently enough that
he's starting to get the just Pearly Things effect where people
like just want him to [__] go away. Like actually
just [__] off, man. I don't know I don't know why
you're talking about this guy now. It's another guy you're talking
about. Can you just [__] off, actually? Can you just
leave?
Can you just go away? Like we actually don't want you around.
Just leave. Just [__] off. Please.
For the love of god, man. Just [__] off.
Okay. All right, we're back to Was it this guy or this guy? It's
this guy.
I feel like he does this [__] to cloud farm off you.
There's no way his community is as large as ours. There's just
more vociferous and more prolific online. He lashes out. I know,
but the reason why I'm showing Guy is spurting out in Twitch
chat. Yeah, I ignored him. The guy who is spurting out in Twitch
Shoutout Ben Dude. I I blocked him from my overlay so I don't
see him. Um here, I'll I'll time him out. He can go to the Kick
chat. Um LeBron James' hairline, if you go to the Kick chat,
um I'm going to ban you. If you go to the Kick chat, you will
give me money when you type all these spurt messages and then
that's based. So, kick.com/jayslocke,
head over there and then when you're spurting, it will give me
money. So, I would I would appreciate that. >> Join this
kind of stuff is so that people understand that this isn't like
every now
I like deleted him. I banned him and then I lost all the messages.
>> check in and explain to you what I have to be dealing
with, right? And then also on top of that, so that you're on
the lookout for, you know, bad faith actors like this if I go
outside. Jesus.
He's He's getting in those gums right there. Do you hear that
sound?
That was like a loud crack. Oh, it's a
Was it No, it's a I bet you it's one of those floss sticks, eh?
He's flossing his teeth on stream?
Brother, what?
Bro, it's mad. Do I think platforms should take action against
people like this? Yes, I do. I think this goes Like it's it's
actually too far, right? It is actually too far.
And it sucks cuz you don't want to give attention to people who
are doing [__] like this, but it is now going just
too far where he's doing this [__] in his private
chat that he controls knowing or hoping that platforms won't
take any action because it's off platform,
That's why he's doing it. He does it in his chat. That's why
he very rarely or I guess he just did it on YouTube. He wants
platforms not to take action. That's why he does it first. And
then when he gets called a [__] he will do it on
YouTube, I guess. It's very predictable, but uh it's just it's
stupid. It really shouldn't be allowed to keep happening. far
beyond just like having reasonable political disagreements, you
know what I mean? You're like actively demanding to your cult-like
fan base
Oh, no, I'm not talking about him. Wait. I I am also talking
about him him flossing his teeth. If he's doing that on stream,
he should do that somewhere else. I just checked and the YouTube
VOD is deleted. Of course, it is. Um it's
bruh. actively dem Um you can still report the channel and explain
exactly why you're reporting him. Give a tweet give a link to
one of the tweets that include this clip and say he broadcasted
on YouTube and deleted the VOD. You can still report that channel.
>> fan base uh that that they go out and find me in the
wild and like harass me. Or maybe do something else other than
harass me, then it'll be fine, you know? That'll it'll be it'll
be good. It's fine. Yes, I think if you're clearly directing
your fans to go and like hunt someone down, then yeah. So, yeah.
Oh, yeah, Rage said don't talk to him, loss, you'll get cooked.
If you do the same asthma method and stay in your circle jerk,
you can be a bot and just think you're right 24
Okay, he's moved on. We We covered this stuff. So, Dibby Bobby
says he usually spurts like this when something bad happens to
him. I suspect his YouTube appeal got denied again. I mean, that
seems like the most likely thing.
I just don't understand even if he makes the appeal through,
like I don't I don't know what he was doing today. It just seems
like he's trying to get terminated. I don't I I truly don't follow
him.
I don't know if you heard what came out about Techtone, but you
could have a case against them. They're threatening your life
and defaming you. Both have had horrible things come out in the
legal system, let alone. I know. Yeah, I
This is like basically the only thing I I'm like going to say
you should be reported for is if you're like basically arguing
that you should You're trying to get your entire fan base to
stalk somebody, to dox them, to harass them.
Calling for extreme harm. I It just seems like that's way over
the line. You can't really allow that.
It sucks to even say it cuz I don't want I don't I really don't
want anyone deplatformed like for the most part. It's like the
one thing, man. >> Anyway, um moving on. Yeah, Techtone
stuff Techtone stuff we'll get to in a little bit, but like I
mean that's another one of those
Okay, where are we going after this? This was like the primary
thing I wanted to cover today was just the Hasan couple Hasan
comments.
Hasan doing nothing and winning is very funny to me every single
time. Palate cleanser, what is this? I noticed you linked this
earlier. Did I open it I did. Will Stancil Oh, you stupid getting
shot at in tear gas is the funniest thing you'll see all weekend.
Oh god. Oh god. Right Oh, it's right egg nationalist. Dude, right-wingers
hate this guy so much. >> They're shooting [laughter] at
me. They are shooting at me. WATCH IT, DOG. OH, YOU STUPID THUGS,
WHAT ARE YOU
HEY, ARREST THESE GUYS. THEY'RE COMING FOR US.
They're coming for us.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING? You can DO IT, NOT US. YOU CAN DO IT. OH,
WHO GIVES A CRAP? I GOT GAS MASKS.
I DON'T CARE.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING? WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
HE'S GOT TO PUT HIS MASK ON AND THEN HE'S GOING TO get pepper
balled.
And like right as he goes to put his mask on, you can hear the
pepper balls
They're They're at me.
They are shooting
They're shooting at me. They're shooting at me. It do be like
that, Mr. Stancel. It do be like that.
Uh the Stancel Waffen will cleanse the streets of Minnesota,
okay? The Stancel Waffen will cleanse the streets.
Arise. Assemble, Stancel Waffen. You have work to do, okay? Assemble.
OH, YOU STUPID THUGS. WHAT ARE YOU DOING? [screaming] HEY, ARREST
THESE GUYS. THEY'RE COMING FOR US. THEY'RE coming for us.